It was founded in 2000.
Originally we had grade seven through
nine of for 200 students designed as a
college prep school.
And uh,
in 19,
uh,
in 2005,
we expanded the school and move to a new
location.
And so today we're serving a 1100
students in kindergarten through twelfth
grade and these are inner city kids.
I started teaching back in 1995 and did
that for five years in the urban core of
Kansas City.
And then another fellow,
and I have also a former CEO got
together and decided to start our own
school.
And this was at the time when charter
schools were starting to take the
country by storm.
And uh,
uh,
so we,
did some planning and sure enough we
were able to
give birth to a school.